Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up on today's episode of the podcast, I am talking to Dr. Juliette Young about ways that we can be more creative in the work that we do with our clients and service users.
We're also talking about how she got into psychology and what her experiences were like of doing her training during the pandemic. She also offers us her top tips for reducing burnout as an aspiring psychologist. Hope you find this episode so useful. Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I love being able to introduce you to the backstories of people you may already have heard of or you may already follow on social media and today's guest might well be one of those people because she does wonderful illustrations all about mental health and working as a psychologist. We are talking to Dr. Juliette Young, also known
as Creative Clinical Psychologist. You will get to learn the backstory of how she ended up in psychology and also one of the other professional psychology disciplines that she considered before becoming a clinical psychologist. Let's dive in and hear all about it and I'll catch you on the other side. Hi, I just want to welcome along Dr. Juliette Young to the podcast, who is a qualified clinical psychologist and also a really creative clinical psychologist too. Hi, Juliette. Hiya. So we first crossed paths because somebody had said they'd love to see us talk to one another and that was over on Twitter forward slash x whatever it is these days. Before we get into you and your fantastically creative illustration ways can we have a little
bit of a think about you and psychology? Yeah, yeah, sure. So how did you... What would you like to know? Everything. When did you first take an interest in psychology and how did that unfold for you? When I was back in secondary school, actually, I wasn't very well behaved in secondary school and I would often be sent to the head teacher's office or the deputy head's office. And I had been watching Tanya Byron's Little Angels I don't know whether people will remember that or whether aspiring psychologists are old enough to remember that but it was a TV show that a psychologist went in and helped parents to think about their children's behaviour through a kind of needs-based lens so I was I was
really fascinated by that and interested. And then in school, when I would be sent to the teacher's office, I would kind of bring in this, well, they need to be doing this better. They need to be thinking about this. And the deputy headteacher at the time said to me, Juliet, you should be an educational psychologist. And of course, I didn't know what that meant but that sort of stuck with me so I guess that's that's kind of where it began. I love that they didn't just see you as being precocious and put you back in their box they thought she's kind of good at this we should probably help her cultivate this. Yeah. Nice so then then presumably you went off to university to study psychology
yes so I did a I did a BTEC at college I I didn't do the normal route of of A levels and within that was a kind of a module on psychology and that's where I I fell in love with it and then after a year out um decided that actually I did want to go to university and then yeah applied and got on studied at UWE to do my undergraduate. Great and did you then fall in love with clinical psychology during your undergrad degree or did that come later? No so I had no idea what clinical psychology was probably until I don't know six or seven years ago actually um so that would have been yeah I started that 16 years ago so there's a big chunk where I didn't know what clinical psychology was um and it wasn't until I knew what educational psychology was
because my teacher had mentioned it and I I got a job after my under working in like an eating disorder, a home for people with eating disorders really. And decided through that that I really did want to pursue a career in educational psychology. So I went and got a job in a school and then worked there for six months, went and got a job in another school, worked there for five years, and within that time applied for educational psychology. And I didn't get on. And actually, within that process, so yes, it was around about the same time as I read a book called, again, by Dr. Tanya Byron, A Skeleton Cupboard. What that book does is it gives, I think it's four case studies and talks about these people and their difficulties
and really it sort of formulates. And that really captured me and really made me think, actually, maybe I really like this idea of formulation and thinking about people's needs. And yeah, so I then decided that I needed to get a job within the NHS and get some experience in mental health services. So I got a job working on crisis teams they're known as in Bristol and intensive teams they're also called in the broader trust that I work in and just doing bank shifts so yeah so adult mental health services and then also decided I wanted to do a masters to just try and get my head into clinical psychology so I ended up this
there's probably a long there's a bit of a long story behind this but i ended up going to the university of east london um to study clinical and community psychology um now when i applied for this i kind of went on it because i was really captured by community psychology and what the the course outline was um without really realizing that how far east the University of East London is from Bristol and I would get up at four or five in the morning, get on a coach, get to central London, go for a day of lectures and then do the same return journey. So I did that for a year, well not quite a year, I think it was eight months once a week um and then alongside that um and while doing the crisis work also got a job as my first job as an assistant psychologist lovely gosh yeah that is quite the commute isn't it I don't know you only need one
decent train strike or delay and it just sends your whole day into chaos yeah I think there was a time when I think it was the Beast from the East, I don't know whether you remember that, when there was that huge few days of snow and I ended up getting on a coach and going to London for all the lectures to be cancelled and then being stuck in London, having to stay at a friend's house.
Oh gosh. But I think what you're really nicely portraying is that actually as an aspiring psychologist we can really spread ourselves very thinly um you know expecting ourselves to be in several places at the same time and you know trying to learn whilst also probably being quite stressed and pressured um and holding many different yeah thoughts in our head and responsibilities you know it's not easy stuff is it no and I think I think you've got to want it and I think you've got to I guess it's about there's there's a a lot of hard work that goes into building that portfolio is it I guess of experiences and but I also think there's there's something about values and for me like going and doing
the masters in UEL like that was I was so inspired by the lectures especially the ones around community psychology and we had a term of doing critical psychology as well that I it didn't feel exhausting or hard if I felt very energized by it I felt very inspired and I felt very I guess it really confirmed to me that I wanted to work in clinical psychology because I could do those things that I kind of saw as educational psychology like working with a wider system thinking in a kind of more systemic way but also yeah but also meeting those needs of kind of wanting to be able to do therapy and I guess it's working across those systems like Bronf and Brenner's ecological systems theory I'm going off on a tangent but yes it's really hard, it's really hard
I think and yeah I was I think I was very fortunate to have had quite a lot of experience behind me at the point I decided I wanted to go into that so that kind of acted as a bit of a platform to get my job as an assistant psychologist and to you know get onto the master's course and to be able to be working in a kind of a flexible job doing crisis work to enable me to fund my master's and and to be able to fund you know my rent and stuff like that as well so it's yeah it's it's tough yeah you know um one of the themes in the clinical psychologist collective book was this perseverance um and that you really need it because otherwise at any point you could be like know um one of the themes in the clinical psychologist collective book was this perseverance and that you really need it because otherwise at any point you could be like oh i'm just gonna not
bother i'm gonna go and do something else whereas you know the more and more you persevere the more and more likely you are to actually get to where you need to be to get on the doctorate to get qualified it's it's a lot um you know it is a lot and I remember as I was listening to you speak it was reminding me of when I was doing my master's and I was working full-time while studying a master's part-time whilst I'd also had a car accident I had back problems I'd just broken up with a partner as well there was like there could not have been any more going on in my life and yet it was that year that I did my successful form to get on to the doctorate you know it's like someone might have said to me at any point oh why don't you just
not apply this year there was would never have been a question but I wasn't going to apply that year you know anytime I wasn't osteo or physio or all crying about my I was working on my form like there was there was never a chance I wasn't going to do it and actually I did get on that year and it the back's fine now the back was fine by the time I started training but it's that that continual motion isn't it you have to you have to want it you know and I guess the support systems around you have to be good enough that you don't burn out yeah and I think that I think you have to want it and I think it's also okay to take a break from it I didn't I was very driven but I had also had sort of taken a break from it and I'd had that you know I'd had several years where I just enjoyed
working and enjoyed my job working in a school and I wasn't really thinking I was you know I had it in my head what that I wanted to be educational psychologist, but I also really focused on just enjoying my job and growing myself within that. So I guess it's about maintaining that drive, but also there's not a time pressure. I think a lot of aspiring psychologists I've spoken to feel like there's this real urgency to get on. And I completely understand it because if you want something, you want it to be, you know, happening. And if there's a risk, it might not happen. You really, you know, you want, there's that uncertainty and sitting with that uncertainty. But what I always say is that actually that time before training was probably some of the best part of my career so far in that I you know I had
a lot more freedom before you know there's once you're qualified there's a lot more responsibilities and a lot more you know things that you have to do that actually when you're an assistant or when I was working in in the job in the school that yeah you have this sort of freedom and and yeah I would always say to people like training is just one part of your journey. And like, you've got your entire, you know, working life. And to really think about that, actually, it's okay, just to enjoy what you're doing. And obviously, there's financial implications, like, it's really difficult to be, yeah, and that's, that's, it's probably even more so at the moment with the cost of living crisis. But it's really difficult to be on a very low paid job.
And I was for, you know, when I worked in the school and assistant psychologists don't get paid amazingly. And like, yeah, I think I think so. I'm saying that by also, I guess, recognising that there is a financial pressure on people to be able to qualify. And I think, yeah, I think that's that's really difficult isn't it and and other people will have um yeah more difficult financial situations and other factors which put pressure on that like having children and yeah absolutely and thank you for that um really nice compassionate reframe because you're right there is no sometimes people say to me oh you know i really need to be qualified by the time i'm 30 and it's like oh why you know you could still you know live your life whilst you're training if you if you want to you
know you can have a family whilst you're on the course if you want to um you can you can flex it to look how you want it to look and when I graduated from my undergrad I went around the world traveling for six months and had I not had those experiences and the experiences of saving up to go traveling and then the experiences of having an absolute ball with my friends and assistant psychologist I love it when the Facebook memories come up of that time you know that all helped with my resilience and with my you know not burning out and with just having fun along the way so that it wasn't just about psychology. You absolutely need more in the background, don't you? Yeah. Yeah. You have to, you know, your life comes first.
Psychology doesn't come first. And yes, we do. You know, we live in a society which means that our communities don't tend to hold us so we do have to get a job and we do have to be able to fund our lifestyle most of the time or most people tend to need that and and um but your life you know you've got to prioritize that because yeah it's really important isn't it is who you are it's what gives you your nourishment and yeah I think that that is yeah or one part of what gives you your nourishment. Yeah I totally agree so what year did you start training as a clinical psychologist then? So I started 2019 so started four years ago been qualified a year. Amazing and how has that journey been for you transitioning from trainee to qualified? I think it's been yeah I think it's been generally a good one I think that training was very challenging because we trained the pandemic hit six months into training and and
there were lots of challenges that came with that in terms of placements I mean it gave us more time to be at home because we didn't have to travel to lectures because lectures are online but lots of challenges that came with that in terms of placements. I mean, it gave us more time to be at home because we didn't have to travel to lectures because lectures are online. But I wonder the impact of that on how much information I retained from lectures, just sat staring at a screen. And yeah, my placements were tricky because a lot of them were remote. I don't work very well remotely I like being somewhere like being among people that's kind of how I work best um so I would say that I probably haven't got a comparative experience other than people who trained at
you know the similar time or through the pandemic um but I really enjoyed qualifying and being able to just be in the office more and to go into a job that I loved. And not that I didn't enjoy some of my placements, but there were some, you know, there were some real highlights in some of my placements. But ultimately, where I'm working now is the area that I want to be in. And therefore, it's very values based and it meets that need to you know to be working with my values and with my interests and I think so yeah so I think an easy transition I would say I was definitely ready to qualify I was definitely ready to you know to get out into the world and you know that's not to say that I wasn't training wasn't really important there's lots of gaps that I probably still need to fill and and learning is an ongoing journey
isn't it so I don't mean it in the way that oh yeah you know I just knew everything and I needed to leave but in that I was ready to go and start the next stage yeah yeah and I guess as I hear you talk I guess I'm wondering if there's a niche in the market for doing some research into whether the pandemic cohorts have actually had a more autonomous experience, that it's felt, I don't know, somehow less protected or that you're kind of having to just do more self-directed stuff and having to really force yourself to concentrate and focus. As we know happens when we're trying to Zoom learn, you know, there's always other things going on. Whereas if, like you said, if you're in the room, if you've got your cohort there, you kind of, you have to show up.
You have to be concentrating as much as you can. Yeah. And I think that, yeah, it'd be really interesting for someone to look into that. And I also think that there's room for one thing that I think clinical psychology doesn't have is kind of like a yearly refresher or like a two yearly refresher where you have to go back and do some of those things and think about those skills and gaps or I don't know. And I guess that might not work if you're in a very specialist area. But having the opportunity to be able to refresh, I think, would mop up some of those gaps, which, yeah, I think during the pandemic was it was just really hard to learn and to stay engaged.
And you're not having that contact with others other than on the WhatsApp group. And, you know, I was lucky enough to have a very good friend who lives on the roads next to me but other than that there's not that contact time um and I think that's that's a really vital part of training actually is learning from your peers and I feel like I missed out on a lot of that it really is but I think also the training is as much about instilling your confidence in yourself as it is teaching you the stuff. So I remember I was actually unwell for the half a day on the training for how to work with people with a bipolar presentation. Half a day for that. That ended up being kind of quite a key part of my qualified life is working with people within that disorder and I still sometimes wonder like would I be better at this if I'd had that half
a day training and of course we know the answer is no because what can you possibly hope to learn about a whole kind of way of working with people and understanding and conceptualizing difficulties in half a day you you just can't, you know? I think that's really true. And actually, you know, what's the saying? Jack of all trades, master of none, that you come out of training with these tiny pockets of things. So, yeah, it probably actually is that there is,
I wouldn't have retained all of that stuff, whether I was doing it online or not but I definitely think yeah I identified with that as well I missed um the ACT training for our CAMHS so CAMHS um or acceptance and commitment therapy for CAMHS um and then also for the adult um and I missed both of them I had I was ill for one I had a funeral for the other and I like I just didn't have time to catch up on the lecture notes I think I probably had a look at them but it's not the same as being in a lecture and all the time now because ACT is something that I think I'm really I really identify with with values and thinking you know in the the work I'm doing around
um with young people with their asylum claim there's you know as we're going along there's not much we can do about the process which is a very long process so it's helping them think about um you know accepting the situation they're in and what can they do within that to I guess find pockets of happiness through meeting their values whatever so I have a kind of loose idea of what act is but I don't feel like I fully understand it I feel like that's a big gap that I need to, yeah, I need to go and revise and I'd miss during training. I'd say there's always time.
And, you know, even now I'm experiencing and, you know, enjoying learning about new topics and new areas. I love an audio book. And so that's a really nice way for me to learn things. You know, you are fairly newly qualified and you can just give yourself time to bed into being qualified and just, yeah, turn to more, you know, learning and enhancing your learning needs as and when the time is ready, I would say. So you've told us really nicely a little bit about some of the qualified work you do there. I think you work a split post, am I right in saying? Yeah, yeah. So in teams that are sort of attached to each other.
But yeah, two different distinct roles, both clinical psychology roles. Brilliant. Are you happy to say a little bit more? You don't have to identify the service you work in or anything, but are you happy to say a little bit more you don't have to identify the service you work in or anything but are you happy to say a little bit more yeah yeah yeah yeah so I work so two days a week I work in um a service for children in foster care um and that is mainly working with the systems around young people although I have got a few young people that I see weekly for therapy sessions um and that's where I worked as an assistant psychologist as well so it was sort of like coming home um and I really love that work I really like the complexity I like working with systems I like thinking about attachment and trauma I'm really interested in
in kind of developmental trauma and the impact of that and how I guess how that can be some of that can be repaired um so that's the two days a week and then two and a half days a week um I work a nine day fortnight um two and a half days a week is in the asylum seeker and refugee clinic um and that is working with children seeking asylum families as well um and um it's primarily a trauma service so we've got quite a narrow commissioning in that it is it is just you know working around post-traumatic stress and um yeah but that is prevalent in in that population because most people who have had to leave their country of origin have experienced you know horrific trauma, either when they were there or on their journey. So, yeah, so a lot of our children, a lot of our referrals meet our criteria anyway.
I once did a very specialist piece of work linked to a GP who specialised in supporting asylum seekers and refugees. And it was just, oh, I just, I learned so much about being human and humble and really, I guess, really, like you said, boiling down those core values of what's important to me, what's important to them, and how we can kind of try and help people find some sort of stability in a world that feels like it's just swirling and ever-changing really tricky stuff yeah I think that's that's a really it's really yeah it's I think that's really kind of hit that hit the nail on the head in the in the kind of the swirling got an image in my mind of this yeah the kind of swirling stuff around them and I as an example I did an assessment last week and I drew out Bronfenbrenner's
ecological systems theory and kind of talked about as a way of validating like I know all of this stuff is you know going on in on your in your country of origin and the impact of seeing that on social media I know that your your asylum claim is really causing you lots of stress. I know that things within the system around you is really stressful. And unfortunately, I might be able to write a letter to the solicitor to give them a nudge to give you some more information. I might be able to do some drawings to try and make a shift in the wider system, even if it's a very minute mute shift but ultimately the we're restricted to working you know with you and and with with just within the individual and and i
think that's yeah i think it's really hard for people to to get and understandably so because actually if your mental health and well-being is being impacted or the main the main difficulty um for you are these other things going on in your life and somebody is sitting down in a room with you to do therapy and you're like well that's that's not what I need I need that other stuff to change and and so it's I think it's yeah it's an interesting job to be in because actually a lot of the time you're working within systems which are making people more unhappy, more stressed. They're exacerbating some of their symptoms. Like it's a real challenge to do that. And sometimes I really question when people are like, this isn't going to be, why would would doing some you know breathing exercises and and um you know muscle relaxation that's not going to change the fact
that I've got an asylum claim hanging over me which might send me back to a country where I'm killed and and it's sort of you know you it's it's very it's very you've got to be very careful I think to make sure that you're validating alongside what you're offering. Yeah validation was absolutely the word that I was thinking of but also just extending some compassion and sometimes just being seen for where you're at right now and having a space to kind of explore how that feels can be wonderfully transformative. Yeah I think relationships and if I sort of look through the lenses the attachment lenses that in my other role and apply them within the role with asylum seeking children is thinking about actually safe relationships and you know I think
it's the trauma recovery model that actually the bottom of it is safe relationships therapeutic relationships and I think that yeah if I can offer that space even if we don't do the trauma work that we're we're kind of there to do it's giving somebody an experience of somebody who is safe and containing and listening and in a world that's very hostile you know yeah just the the context which is very hostile if you're a young asylum seeker especially if you're unaccompanied arriving in the UK then that is you know that's somebody who's giving something that is the opposite to hostile and and I guess somewhere along the line will will give you a sense of safety in the world even if it's a very small one. Absolutely and I find myself kind of drawing comparisons between foster care systems so when I work with people in the asylum seeking role people
contacted me kind of years later to say you know thanks and actually that made a real difference and just being able to hear your voice at times that felt really challenging and being able to draw upon some of the stuff we'd done actually really did make a difference and it's knowing that you can kind of you can still check back in you know if if they want to. So we don't kind of lead that ourselves. But I don't know, maybe years down the line, people will come back to you and say, gosh, that was really incredibly powerful. And I think that's a really nice thing
that you get to be part of someone else's story, even though you may never know that you're still being held in mind. It's a real magical thing we do, I yeah so it's a it's a real privilege I think isn't it um to be in that position um and yeah to be able to have that sort of impact on people's lives and to be with them and and a lot of the trauma work I do, like it's such an honour for people to share their story with me. Like it really is like an amazing honour to hear and witness, you know, their story and some of the really awful things that they've never shared with anyone since they've arrived in the UK. Other than maybe on their, you know, in a very formal way in their in their application but in you know thinking about the
emotional impact thinking about yeah but I guess being alongside them in an emotional way in in sharing that is like a deep privilege like it really is like yeah I'm very lucky to have that really yeah and that the ability to be able to kind of help them de-shame that process as well is, you know, amazing. So important. So tell us a little bit then about your wonderful illustrations and how you started to weave that into your clinical work with people? Well, I guess, I mean, I have always drawn and illustrated, you know, my whole life, really. So it's and so it's sort of a natural, a natural thing to bring it into my work. And when, you know, when I worked in the school, I would be doing sessions with young people and I would be drawing to try and help, you know, think about ideas.
And it often takes the focus off that kind of dyad doesn't it it it takes a different focal point and enables conversation so I think I'll probably bring it into my clinical or have been bringing it into my clinical work for a long time I guess that when it kind of ended up getting like publicly coming into view. Is that what you mean? Like, how does it kind of evolve? Or do you mean? Yeah. So I guess I mean, I just bought a tablet in the pandemic about I think it's about three years ago and thought I would share some drawings on various concepts. And and yeah, just gave it a go and and yeah it just became really popular and it still sort of surprises me now that everyone likes my drawings so much and and
I think I put one yesterday that was about um compassionate leadership and it's you know sort of a thousand people have liked it and there's lots of shares and lots of comments in it and and I think that it yeah the feedback i've had is that people find it really useful to use in their clinical work to to kind of distill ideas down into a visual concept and and that that can be really useful you know because there's lots of really complex concepts in psychology aren't there and and we live in an increasingly visual world so yeah so that's that's kind of what I hope to do that's sort of what's ended up happening and it's ended up you know I do various other there's been various offshoots from it now which I really enjoy so I did see the one
you mentioned I think it was like it was almost like a waterfall like was that like a rainbowy waterfall it was really really nice really nice and I'm just in awe of you because um I just I'm just not very good at art I have these wonderful ideas in my head and then that doesn't come out of my pen like it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't translate but you do yours on a tablet do you so is that how that like are you like an apple pen kind of girl how does it work practically I don't I don't have a I don't have an iPad I've got Samsung people I always get messages saying what do you what do you do these on and people often think that it's on an app actually and there's like a clip art image and I'm just bringing them together but
it's all hand-drawn so I yeah so I just I've got a an app called Ibis which is I don't think it's like a well-known one at all but it's just what I started using and now I'm most familiar with and yeah I'll just draw them and and it can take sometimes they can be very quick sometimes it can take me hours and hours and hours and I really enjoy you know I really enjoy doing it it's very therapeutic for me to sit down and draw and just have the creativity or the time to be able to be creative, actually the freedom to be able to kind of create. And I think in pictures. So I often, you know, I think in like I see concepts and I kind of I'm visualizing all the time things. So it's it's just kind of kind of yeah putting that that then gets translate translated into yeah drawing it and sometimes they're not that good either people sort of say
oh like I quite like your scruffy little drawings like I just think that sometimes there's like a wonky arm and it like kind of it doesn't all come together but and there's some that I've done which I sort of look at and just think that's awful um But yeah, there's there's yeah, that's just sort of how how it comes together, really. I like that. I think life is imperfect, isn't it? And sometimes it doesn't need to be pristine and polished. And I'm sure it's still even your scruffy ones that you don't like are still far above what I get to achieve. How did you start to think about putting putting your ideas down into a book how did that come about? So I was contacted actually by an
editor from Jessica Kingsley Publishers and she just contacted me saying I really like your drawings I like how you sort of distill concepts down and your explanations as well like would you be interested in in doing a book in like maybe kind of a I think she suggested maybe a clinical psychology one or CBT or sort of an area and I like you know I was honoured when she emailed me that because I just thought that's you know what a privilege for somebody to be thinking about um you know offering you that opportunity and yeah and then that that formed into I actually contacted two of my lecturers because I thought if I'm going to do a an illustrated guide to clinical psychology lecturers who teach on courses about clinical psychology are the best place to go. And I contacted one who's very, not very actually, that's probably unfair, but she's a CBT, she's a qualified CBT therapist.
And I guess kind of gives that more CBT lens. And then I also contacted my research supervisor at the time who, I guess, took more of a critical lens towards clinical psychology and some of those more community psychology values and then yeah and then we all got together and then yeah created the the proposal and then that got accepted and then yeah April April this year I was it was like a second thesis trying to finish it off and trying to finish off the illustrations and stuff amazing so we're recording this at the tail end of 2023 um but we're very much planning that this episode is going to come out when your book is available so tell us what it's called tell us where you're imagining it might be available for purchase tell us all of those good things
so it's called an illustrated guide to clinical psychology and yeah it's by my myself Juliette Young and then Dr Catherine Butler Dr Rachel Pascal um and it's going to be available on Amazon I think it's already available for sort of pre-sale and yeah major bookshops um we're also doing a book launch, which I think may be on, I think it's the 27th, 28th in Bath. So if you're in Bath, but there'll be information about that on my Instagram page and on my Twitter page, closer to the time around that. Brilliant. How exciting, your very own book launch what an exciting book baby to be launching on the world yeah so your ideal client for that is an aspiring
psychologist is that the is that that's the ICA yeah yeah so uh aspiring psychologists um we also talked about it just being useful for newly qualified psychologists and also those who might be working alongside clinical psychologists and wanting to understand what it is as a profession, you know, to have find it useful to reference for another section someone else has written on, on, I don't know, cognitive analytic therapy. And just to remind myself what the key principles is very much an intro and summary. So there's, you know, a page or two per idea, per therapy modality, per approach. There's stuff around, yeah, the first chapters on kind of the history and some context. And there's stuff around um yeah the first chapters on kind of the history and some context and there's stuff around key skills so it's yeah it's a pick up flick and you know put down or you know or you might want to read it back to front but it's yeah sort of for anybody that it might
be useful to really it sounds brilliant have you designed your cover as well i'm imagining it's brilliantly illustrated yes so yeah the cover is the cover was I gave the illustrations it's been put together by a graphic designer actually because that's yeah that's not one of my strengths or at least something I've not tried before is the kind of the composing things in a graphic design way so and have you have you seen it yet have you held it in your hands as yet? Not a physical copy. We had the final proof, just PDF sent through the other day, which is, yeah, sort of bizarre to see, you know, the ISB numbers or the, you know,
and we've had some endorsers who have read it and given some comments on it. And it's, yeah, it feels, yeah, it's just really exciting. Like I did, I remember sitting down with um one of the other trainees a year into training and sort of talking about wanting to take it a bit easy on training and say oh it's not like we're going to write a book or anything and then here I am you know four years later with my book coming out in a few months it just yeah I love that and um if people want to learn more about you or follow you on socials, where should they head, Juliet? So Instagram's probably the best place. So I'm creative.clinical.psychologist.
I've recently set up an Instagram for my Dr. Juliet Young. Brilliant. Thank you. I'll make sure there's details in the show notes for how people can follow you there will also be details in the show notes of how you can buy juliet's book as well which is available now as we are looking at future march 2024 so thank you so much for your time wishing you the absolute best of luck with your first book baby I hope it flies really well for you and really makes a difference and helps people understand what it is that we do and perhaps feel a bit more contained
and understood by those around us as well. Yeah, yeah, I hope so. And you've given us lots of lovely advice to reduce burnout along the way in clinical psychology as well. So thank you for sharing that with us. And thank you for sharing your time with us too. thank you for having me on i've really enjoyed talking to you today marianne oh thank you likewise now how incredible please do go and follow juliet over on
instagram creative clinical psychologist and her book is available now so check out the details in the show notes or if you look on my social, you'll be able to see links to the book as well. Hope you found that interesting. I love the way that psychology allows us to blend our skills, our interests and our passions into our clinical work. I'd love to know what you think to this episode.
Come and let me know over in the free Facebook group, the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. Please do also subscribe and like if you're watching on YouTube. And why not consider checking out the Aspiring Psychologist membership, as well as my own books, the Aspiring Psychologist Collective and The Clinical Psychologist Collective book. Thank you so much for being part of my world. And I will look forward to catching up with you for the next episode of the podcast, which will be available from 6am on Monday. Take care. then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified
it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything
will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.